[Music]
hey guys welcome to our very first Q&A
video really excited to answer all your
questions it was pretty overwhelming we
didn't expect so many of you guys asked
so many questions so unfortunately we
can't answer them all in this video but
we picked a few or top-10 yeah our top
10 so we'll be answering ten questions
all right but before we get into
answering your questions this video is
sponsored by best fiends I'm really
really excited about this because I'm a
huge best fiends game addict I'm on
level 86 I've been playing this game
non-stop I really love this game you
have the time to play this game all the
time usually when I'm going to bed this
is like my relaxing time that's when I
actually play it how does that dress
pass out because I always test up fell
asleep sport so it's usually I'm playing
while he's sleeping and then Isaac has
helped me get far along in these levels
too because he likes playing this game
so pretty much this game is it's a free
puzzle game where you collect like the
same colored pieces and you use your
fiends to attack the slug the reason why
I really like this app as well is
because they have these finish games and
it just released this game called boot
camp where the slugs are actually
training against the fiends and you get
to see the the reverse perspective of
the game because usually you are playing
as the themes trying to defeat the slug
baby so I'm actually really excited to
play that and if you guys check out the
link in the description box below you
will see a link for you to download the
app and once you download you'll get
five dollars worth of gold and diamond
and once you start playing this game
you're going to know that you really
mean these things because it helps you
build up your themes we need to have
stronger fiends who are you you live
like a double life
I'm looking into it I know I like I like
okay we meet load alright now let's get
into the question question number one
from Sophia TV what is your most
favorite thing about each other what's a
favorite thing about me ah my favorite
thing about you is your passion my
passion you're very passionate about
everything in your life and I think it's
because of the fact that you are so into
movies so like you picture your life as
a movie so everything has to be like in
like inspiring and there's a lot of
passion there's a lot of passion in your
work in our relationship and the way you
are with Isaac is just you're all about
passion that's very little about you so
romantic
yeah you're really arm and a lucky girl
guys yeah I think my most favorite thing
about you is your curiosity you're a
very curious person like you don't leave
any stones unturned is for me I can live
life without ever finding out about
certain things I'm probably knows me I
don't care
you are nosy but in a very good way
because you're not knowing that you're
not curious in a way where you're nosy
and you have to find out about things to
get an advantage on certain things you
just you're just curious for the sake of
being curious you want to learn which is
a great reason why you're a great
placement for taking something China's
playing just tour even got it like
that's the same fellow that I love your
curious nature and I love the fact that
you're you're willing to learn
alright so the next question
is from Poncho's art what type of music
do you listen to the reason why we
picked this question that was because we
love you really love music I don't even
know where to begin
so for me either the English side and
the Spanish side and then there's the
side that there's no no I wish I could
say I wish I could good English trends
in Chinese divide but I know this isn't
a Chinese easy to get off I don't like
army you know like country that's like
the two genres that we never really
blend blend very well but outside of
those two genres I think you know like
so music jazz music oh we love raw they
all raw I suggest to all sorts of Jeff
all the entire spectrum of jazz except
for like the really like skinny jean
Kenny G yeah we don't like that kind of
done I don't even know what it's called
but like the internet Kelly you Chi yeah
he doesn't know a lot of the music me
and your brother share a lot already
doesn't new too many like I don't like
modern music there's so much more to
explore with old music than there is
with music that I get really actually
get really bored music now it's simple
yeah I tend to listen to older music -
mainly jazz mainly rock rock yeah just
to give you guys a little insight of
what we really love to listen to we have
our own playlist and then playlist is
curated because we like to listen to
this like whenever we're ready to go to
sleep so our playlist
do you love by cat power nothing takes
the place of you by JD McPherson maggot
brain by the Funkadelic free bird by
Lynyrd Skynyrd black magic woman Santana
foxy lady Jimi Hendrix little wing by
Jenny Jimi Hendrix a lot of Jimi Hendrix
wants a cherry says a lot of mana water
rock and then for me is in the Spanish
role I love listening to Villanova like
Shakira back in the day not really renew
stuff that much mana that's like the
number one band in my life they're
selling out - yeah he likes - ooh and I
like listening to van that sometimes I
don't like folios or north daniels with
the exception of input goblets you
do loving to come to so much yeah so we
we love music next question question
number three by Nick tavola 23 oh this
is this is it really this is a juicy
question everyone's asking how do you
feel about Barton geo not coming to
Paris what do you think guys come on
obviously we're sad these are two of our
closest closest friends Gio is my best
friend
of course I'm heartbroken it can't even
make it but you know what I've seen a
lot of comments saying like man Tiffani
still messed up how she's gonna have a
wedding and not have a best friend there
why can't you move the wedding date well
where you guys don't know is we actually
already moved for the wedding date for
Gio so the story is around January and
has first emails our wedding planners we
had finally found a wedding planner out
there in Paris and I told Gio really
excited on my genome we're starting the
wedding planning process and we picked
like a time frame when we want to do the
wedding if she was like cool when are
you gonna have it and then I told you
I'm like well in early September and
then her face kind of changed some
likewise it gives everything okay she's
like no yeah that's awesome not cool and
then a few weeks later that's when she
finally tells everyone that she was
pregnant and then I'm like you know why
did you pregnant my god I'm so happy
like this is awesome
like what don't you do she's like really
September no no and then Zelda's all
bummed out and I'm like okay first of
all there is no way I'm gonna be in
another country like across the world
while you are in labor that's nothing
that happen
you're my best friend I'm going to be
here for you we're not going to have the
wedding in September anymore like that's
final so then I asked a wedding planner
I said I just thought on my best trying
to spread nations do the same time we
were looking at the wedding dates one
day suggest that we should get married
and then she gave me some more options
and some of them were before she gave
birth and then somewhere after she gave
birth and then I was
telling her own like it's not realistic
to try to plan a wedding with her
traveling with the newborn so I'm like
okay well we're gonna have to do it
before she gives birth
so I even googled like what's the latest
of pregnant lady can fly and I think it
was like 38 weeks or something like that
so that I was like okay well let's see
if we can try to like plan it out
somewhere here so then we finalized on
the month and she bought her plane
ticket she was like okay I asked my
doctor the doctor said I should be good
as like it's pretty much just up to me
how I feel leading up to the date and
then I guess his last time that she went
to the doctor told her I don't recommend
it you're gonna be really far along by
the time this wedding happened so I
don't think you should go and the doctor
was like I'm sure your friend will
understand and then once you're always
telling me I was like yeah of course you
and the baby's health is number one like
who cares about our wedding like that
doesn't matter like you're number one
they'll make sure still it's kind of
hopeful she's like well I still want to
see how I'm gonna feel and I'm like in
my head I'm just like girl it's okay
like though I mean we tried we moved the
date up to see if you can make it it's
not possible oh well like the stock I
guess at this point we can't move the
wedding again because everyone already
bought their ticket omission is way too
crazy now at this point so I'm really
really bummed out that she can't make it
but I mean they're their health is
number one that's the most important
thing I don't know about you by
entertaining the idea like maybe you put
throwing the wedding a whole year or
maybe two years but then that kind of
pushes artists our timeline back as well
you know cuz we have other big plans
that you want to do too so we kind of
need to do this wedding now so that's
all we can't postpone it and I'm not a
bad friend okay I tried really hard to
make sure she can make it I literally
moving my family members from Mexico I
had originally told them what we're
having our wedding in September and they
were like cool we're going to save up
we're going to make sure we're there and
then I tell them sorry guys I had to
move the data because you know like that
want my friend to be or make it and
everyone's like well that's too soon we
can't make it so now I don't have Gio or
my family from Mexico coming to the
wedding so it sucks like all around just
take really sucks but we have bigger
plans that we we need to make sure that
we're on time for our next question is
from Parker Conant
das a cool name Parker Conan Conan with
u n when are you two planning on making
a baby chance baby chance well that's
that big thing that we're trying to plan
for and yeah we want so we realize geo
and Kristina are pregnant and we do want
to have a kid of our own eventually that
can also grow up with their kids you
know and kind of create a group of kids
that are within the same age range but
we don't want to have this kid without
being married you know and so that's why
we're really pushing for this Larry my
eyes on this for some Hillerman first
I'm like we're having another kid we
have to be very alert yeah and
everything's kind of pointing in that
direction for us like Isaac's for you to
have a sibling I'm ready for years
not everyone is I'll hold on baby wait I
gotta get married first yeah and I'm
like you know I think we're ready for a
kid like we're super ready for it now
everyone in our lives getting into that
age where you know starting a family is
a very high priority now and then also
our parents who like my parents been
wanting a grandchild I've never really
felt that pressure from them until maybe
it's like two years ago it was when they
finally started like hinting at the idea
hey when are you going to start learning
to pop the questions that you can get
moving along with you know other bigger
things you know and I'm like oh it's
just got like real grown-up now that's
why we couldn't push them on the wedding
even longer pretty much the timeline
that we have going on here this is just
like a general sense of direction we
don't know if we're really going to go
through with this entire timeline but
pretty much what we're thinking is get
married spend a whole year of just being
married and joins of married life
without throwing a kid in the mix yeah
and that's one we will think about
trying to have a kid
he's completely ready for another one
but me I don't feel all that ready for a
second kid because knit your body
first of all yes it is my body I'm not
ready for my body to go through crazy
crazy drastic changes all over again cuz
I had that happen to me when I was 17 I
got pregnant while seventeen Isaac was
born when I was 18 so it's really really
young and even though I love my baby to
death and I just I love the way
everything happened I still feel like I
kind of missed out on my young adulthood
you got to experience that I didn't I
was a single mom working going to school
it was really hard so I feel like just
now because Isaac's getting older he's
really independent now and you know I
just feel like just now I'm getting to
experience that like adulthood like
without having this stress so much about
having a young little kid while you're
working and doing all these things so
right now I'm really enjoying sort of
freedom that I have because Isaac
soldiering more independent like I feel
like I gained that freedom back so I
don't know if I'm ready to let go of
that just yet but that's why I'm saying
like we'll see we'll see what happens we
got like seeing my friends you know
going through that whole motherhood
experience the first time and it just
it's really really reminiscent for me of
thinking like I remember when I was
pregnant and I remember feeling I just
kicks and my belly and all I kind of
wanted I want that right now I kind of
miss that
so then I'm kind of like going back and
forth so I don't know and then how in
terms of how many kids were planning on
having because I saw that question pop
up a lot we were planning on having a
minimum of two more kids because Isaac
has grown up being an only child and I
grew up being an only child - because my
half-brother was born when I was like 10
years older nine years old so same thing
with anything connect exact same thing
and I don't really feel all that close
to my brothers because I'm so much older
than them and we just didn't really grow
up having that like sibling kind of
relationship for like some future kids
like I want them to be able to grow up
with a sibling like from lenders little
because Isaac didn't get to experience
that I didn't get to experience that I
want to be able to provide that for our
future kids yeah brainerd tyranny and
our power to to try to incorporate Isaac
I mean it's not like we're not doing
that already but like you know given the
fact that when you throw another child
in and you know it's a half sibling I
don't know I don't know what kind of
psychological effects that will have on
Isaac but you know we're going to try
our best to really tend to that and
really nurture Isaac so that he doesn't
feel pushed out in any sort of way
that's why we're thinking a minimum of
two hopefully a boy and a girl because
that's what everyone wants right pulling
a girl in terms of which one would be
first we don't really hear I don't know
it's all cool yeah sugar old is cool too
it's too wide it's cool to enter all
right next question
underscore period Jay cash oh did you
guys ever think you would have made it
this far together that's an easy no no
we didn't why not
because when we first started dating it
was supposed to be a fling it was a
fling now it's supposed to last maybe
just a couple months because you were
trying to date around at that time you
had just gotten out of a long-term
relationship and so you wanted to
explore the dating world and kind of see
what you liked and didn't like yes I
have only been in three relationships in
my whole life the first one being
Isaac's dad lasted three years second
one I was someone else that left for
three years in the third one with you
now five years going on to infinity
treasurers okay so you're supposed to be
my first like fling kind of thing
because I have never experienced that
baby's world like could your first thing
worked out well for you yeah I'm
marrying my first place so then going
into our thing I made it clear like I'm
not trying to be
at all I just got out of a serious
relationship like I want to justify
myself
there's just have fun yeah for me too it
was a fling in the beginning to was out
like oh she has a kid I don't know if I
want to commit myself as that kind of
responsibility that's you know it's a
pretty heavy responsibility and you know
because of that I made it very clear to
myself to that it would be a fling but
you're the one who told me I love you
like two weeks after dying no his
emotions fly and you just can't tell us
at all right now until I was like I
wonder two weeks no wasn't smell I
remember thinking in my head like what
was just some dating for two weeks
here he told me love me but you were
drunk so yeah I'm blown back home this
is Dallas and we're talking on the phone
he was drinking with his dad yeah and he
was like I love you I'm like I'm like
you're good drunk it's okay and then
you're like none I really love you like
I love you I know I do and I'm like I'll
talk to you in the morning
and then so that just ended there and
then he flew back over and we saw each
other not like you know you told me you
loved me over the phone and I remember
you saying something like you you
thought about it and you looked at me
like what's the most like romantic eyes
and you're like I think I do love you
I'm like so yeah that were to be again
nothing not to like about you know
you're just so lovable
good the flame turned into a thing
pretty early on I would say yeah and I
remember when he actually told me like
no I think I really delivered and I told
them I was like listen you can run right
now it's okay I have so much baggage
you can leave I won't be angry I know
it's a lot to like take on mix me with a
kid I'm like alone and I'm doing all
this and I'm just like it's a lot so
like you can run it's okay in case what
would you say I don't know what I do
everybody exactly right so you said
something like no I'm not for it like I
want you I want to do this I don't want
to run away oh I think I remember
because at that time I haven't had an
officially met Isaac yet yeah he had but
seeing how afraid of a mom and like a
person that kiss was I was like oh she's
laying down the path the right path
first time she talks about him every
once in a while you know so if there was
another single mom and child that
whatever has another fling with in the
future you know maybe this this one
right here would be the one to settle
down with you know no it's like you know
I don't know you're just a beautiful
person then it's really hard it has the
funder eautiful people are hard to pass
this on by inside inside okay outside
inside it out come on come on
Kasich in a straight Nick yeah that's
how that started yet but we did not
think we would because it for at all
that's for sure I remember one time we
were staring into the mirror and we're
just kind of like licking our scatter
cells I was like do you think we look
good together
I was like no I said no because I had
never been with anyone outside of my
Latin culture so I had never been with
an Asian guy so just alphabet I was
really ignorant I guess in that time
because it was a little bit like oh this
is kind of awkward I'm with some Asian
guy now I've never been with an Asian
guy so when you ask me that in front of
the mirror like should we look good
together like I don't think so like I
don't really see a lot of like
interracial couples in my own little
Mexican bubble world that I was in at
that time even at that I feel like it
wasn't that common either example Asian
girl is kind of they're able to date
just by any rights by Asian guys I think
at that time was almost specifically
with white girls or Asian girls notice
there wasn't a whole lot of other
ethnicities in the mix and so and I
don't know lately they like to go on
Instagram like I feel a lot a lot of
interracial couples oh that's awesome
we're we're trendy yeah
the next question from at Polytech Kelly
Thursday all right after after Lila hurt
Kelly yeah I love the father/son
parenting relationship between Casey and
Isaac so my question is how did you
introduce I chase the m5 versa
oh we kind of touched on this in the
previous um yeah a little bit so Casey
and I were dating for a couple months
before he ever met
Isaac it was at the OC Fair in 2012 we
all went together and I remember my
brother went oh my god what is that so
my pleasure I think it's a baby Rhett no
it's a lizard are you sure yeah catch it
though kill it
why how do we get it out kind of one
record so again oh he's so cute
very pretty all right we will resume
this in a little bit
what are you doing though hunter mode oh
my god I see it is it a rat well get it
what do we do we can't just leave the
lizard here how do you can get in oh I
see it what do you do you're not gonna
get it you know our Castle gets Chloe
come on go get out get out yes you're me
whoa
get out stupid lizard you're over there
no you're at Rex's oh underneath you
he's under you fool yeah oh sorry though
your playmates gone that was really
scary I don't know how a misery got into
our house but anyways we were on the
question about you meeting Isaac oh yeah
what is your first thought or your first
impression of Isaac like in my mind the
way you speak of me so mature but then
when if I met him only
that's a toddler yeah four years old and
they met so cute you know last night
since we were picking these questions I
wanted to pick eyes
bringing to him I asked him I suppose
your first impression a case when you
met him out first of all do you even
remember meeting casing he was like no I
don't remember it was a long time ago he
hadn't known him for like half of his
life already so um but then I asked him
like what do you remember what you
thought of him or like how you felt when
you met him he was like I thought he was
a cool guy I mean I liked him he was
cool and I'm like oh really and I
thought he was my urges adventure to say
it I was like well have you met anyone
that you immediately didn't like and he
started talking about some girl at
school so he does know the difference is
like immediately having a good
impression or a bad impression you gave
him a good impression so yeah I know you
gave me a really good impression too
you're just really easygoing he's like
one of the most easiest going kids like
when my parents met him they said the
same thing too it's like you know kids
these nightmares yeah it gets him he
nightmares and Isaac is easy to Luckys
he's the dream child so I'm glad he is
that way I mean I made it easy for all
three of us to kind of coexist together
and inform this family I'm lucky mama
cuz I have such a great kids and I was
so funny because in the beginning I
could see how awkward you were with
Isaac here just like here's the door
because I hadn't been around kids for so
long and on in the very first photo I
took of them together I forgot why we
were in the car and I remember thinking
like honest is sweet like this was
around you know the beginning of when
they meet let me take a picture and
remember this and so I took I took a
picture of you and you maybe you're
weird like half smile and I was you kind
of looked angry sort of a little bit and
I was just like he worked around Isaac
yeah I mean kids even like a
mid-twenties guy that dwelled in
Hollywood for the past five years and
not a child in sight you know it does
something to your psychology and to how
you carry yourself and what it was Isaac
is so affectionate to you with consoles
yeah hug him and like tickle them play
with him here
like yes the fast last five years you
know hang out with rappers and at bars
going to shows recording doing music
videos like it's a totally different
world and now I asked like TC myself all
sudden turn you know the rate of our
scene into a rated G scene you know and
I was like I don't know how to do this I
had to like re acclimate myself I didn't
want to introduce them until we knew
that we were a little bit more serious
so that's when I introduced them I think
we're dating for a few months right yeah
yes next question next from Darth sand
heap where did Isaac's name come from
hmm that's all you know you know you
told me the story yeah yeah because
we're talking about how how we would
name our kids and then I was like wow
this is so hard how do you name I do oh
my goodness my entire pregnancy I was
stressing about what am I going to name
this new this brand-new human being that
has to be referred to this particular
name that I have to pick for the rest of
their lives it's a lot of pressure and
then his dad at the time he was just
like well there's his name um after me
and I'm like no we're not doing that and
so he wasn't very like I don't know you
pick it like he didn't really care so I
was all alone ended all of them so the
entire pregnancy I'll just look through
like baby name book and I just didn't
like any of them and whenever I would
come across the name that I'm like ah I
could work because I don't think of
someone that I image that had that name
and it kind of like tarnishes the name
of it even if it's a cool person and
you're just like well I mean that person
already had that name like you kind of
don't want it everyone has I know so
then um at that time the name Aidan was
like super popular and I really like how
it sounds and it's like it is rolled up
it sound really nice and it just sounds
please it's like Damon it's a really
sweet name so that sound like okay and
it's funny that I'm saying I didn't want
to pick a name that other people have
you and then I ended up about to pick up
a name that was really popular at a
non-word but yeah I was about to May 1 8
in the day he was born
I had a cesarean so that's why I might
be cut open my stomach and take them out
until I met you I didn't know
sharing a c-section same thing yes so I
had a c-section so when he came into the
world
I remember that anesthesiologist telling
me like hey it's employee what do you
what's his name and I looked at his dad
and I was like get in and he says I can
wherever you want he didn't care so I
was like come on Ayden so I just I was
just staring up into the ceiling and I
was at that time I was like a lot more
religious so it's like God please please
please God like help me I don't know
what to name this kid I am so scared of
like making the wrong decision like
please God help me like what do I name
this kid and then finally like it just
popped in my head I'm like Isaac Isaac
Isaac's nice I like how it sounds I like
Isaac and I had considered Isaac when I
was pregnant but then I knew someone in
high school named Isaac and I'm like
Madeline anyone with that because of
that reason but then in that moment he's
in such like he's already here he's born
they're asking me what is his name gonna
be that doesn't care I'm like asking God
oh I like to think that God named him
because that name just popped into my
head at that moment and this plus is a
biblical name as well so yes that's how
I was explained came about so and I'm
really happy that I went with that name
or that God helped me pick that name
because I really love that me and it
just fits him perfectly now I don't know
how are we going to new more future kids
at all we think about it sometimes just
to like have fun really what would we
need my future daughters or a future son
and then we don't know let's go really
hi dears
I like peers you know my peers it's not
going to be Pierce was from Maxine's
array Oh dad's a contender Alex desirey
who are your bereavement and bridesmaids
ah wedding question and when I say sit
together 3 2 1 we don't know Oh
yeah we're not we don't have any
groomsmen or bridesmaids because they're
just too many people that we love in our
lives and we didn't want to put that
pressure on them like you have this
title you have this role in our wedding
like we don't want to do that to anyone
so that's the reason why we don't have
any another thing to is everyone that
would be a groomsman bridesmaid we I we
know their schedules you know and they
it's already hectic as it is and to
place more responsibilities on them and
especially if the fact that we're doing
them cares - it's like no they would
have to deal with Paris things and like
I don't want to trouble them so yeah
we're just doing it on our own with the
wedding planner and then whoever wants
to make a speech or whoever wants to do
stuff certain things on the wedding day
were playing it early loose yeah we
really are so it's funny that we our
wedding ended up to being what it is
right now because originally I wanted to
elope I didn't want a big wedding
anymore I was just like we don't need
all their students spend all his money
that's not proper done so everyone out
there is thinking that it's me that
wants a big Paris wedding like or Casey
he doesn't sell out all this money as
you know she is such a princess she
wants all this no guys it wasn't me him
he wanted this big wedding okay well I
didn't want to elope I don't want to
make it oh yeah yeah I don't know I'm
just waiting I'm not like whatever about
weddings too but when it came down to it
I like I guess the way I feel about you
specifically I was like I don't want to
elope with you I won I want to celebrate
you and I want to celebrate with people
that are around me and I want to
celebrate in a place that I really you
know honestly like going to so here's
the romantic when I even told us an
engagement ring when we were talking
about getting engaged and stuff I told
him like please don't get me a real
diamond I'm cool with like a cubic
zirconium diamond like just get me
something looks nice it doesn't matter I
don't care if it's real she's going on
about me I'm no diamond so it's not me
okay guys stop thinking that I'm this
like demanding person
to have a Syrian saying I really don't I
honestly truly don't I was down to just
have a simple wedding like farting jeah
or even more simple than that just go
somewhere I don't know Vegas go to a
Vegas chapel
I don't know why I wanted to get married
and be married and that's it and like
focus on our life but then once he like
laid it out for me like that like yeah
you know we should have like something
special where we bring our families
together and we can also double it as a
vacation kind of like before NGOs it
would be went to Hawaii we're like cool
and then that's when we started
brainstorming like where can we go
around the world like this is fun and
then that's how I kind of grew from
there yeah you're you've actually been a
very easy or firm fiance and wife future
wife to shop for and everything cuz you
don't really you're not very
materialistic sound I'm the one that
likes it upon myself to create a
tradition right a tradition of going to
Tiffany's for every person what is he
yeah and like I put it upon myself to
make that a tradition and that has like
one of myself every year and stuff like
that which meant I'm like but you have
to one-up yourself a few that means yet
the one of yourself and how much you
make every year I made this whole like
thing about you know needing to be
successful like within myself you know
and then that's three years of that she
was like can we stop of the Tiffany's
thinkin too much too much money is like
I tell you every year please don't get
me anything expensive like honestly if
you do want to spend money I'm the type
of person that's like I don't care about
materialistic things I'm all about it
experiences and adventures I'm like give
me a vacation someone I really like
let me very good yeah and online listen
dude looks like experiences or like get
me a class on like how to fly a plane or
something like that like I don't care
about materialistic things I still
appreciate it obviously but I tell you
that every year I'm like don't find
anything yeah that's how that because I
did see that question a lot pop up and
your guys's submissions that's like why
did you guys decide
- Maryum parents are like how much are
you guys paying for the wedding and
actually I've heard this be kind of
common sense that you don't really talk
about dollar amounts when it comes to
wedding or like who's paying for the
wedding which by the way we both are
paying for the wedding okay I saw a lot
of comment cycle for Casey has to shell
out all this money no guys it's our
wedding our money very very cool
yeah but yeah the reason why Paris
though and we actually talked about this
in one of the parrots vlog but while
we've already impaired scouting out
venues and stuff like then and planning
the wedding I realized that one of the
first times I actually communicated with
tip was when I was in Paris and because
of that also always kind of the full
circle kind of thing where it all began
with his Facebook message while I was in
Paris and it'd be really cool to kind of
bring it back to Paris when we get
married and so that's the whole and a
poetic flare of why we're doing in Paris
and I just love hair it's like I love
eating food in Paris that's a lot of
food to offer and then the very first
time we even had Isaac introduced to his
parents was that a French or not here
and I know a write off a sunset yeah so
it's like it's just all kind of points
towards and you know France the one
Pixar movie that we watched or at all
three of a time all the time
ratatouille that's our favorite so
there's plenty of I mean if you really
want to make it a reason why we're doing
Paris there's plenty of things that
indicate yeah so I know we actually not
got a lot of waiting questions with this
one brightly routed mass cruising so
next question from Mary mud for the dish
what is amazing
that means you notice each other what
was it about me that it's just like
alright let's just take it back anyway
so it was after a rap show from mutual
friend of ours and we was asked an after
party at a bar and I was talking to some
other people and I'm just kind of
scanning the room and as they thought
possibly with the with the hopes of
seeing a really really pretty face
somewhere along the way and lo and
behold I see one and with you I know you
were talking some other people had a
drink in your hand
a white top here's what jeans yeah yeah
little purse and it was your eyes though
it was the eyes and your smile that
roads like goes like one of those cans
cans cans get whoa whoa whoa whoa what
is that
and then always like Bowl I need to talk
to her but I don't think I actually got
around to talking to you that night any
meet you that night because of how
magnificent you're smiling like your
eyes are to me how it's like I was a
little bit intimidated it's really half
off I who uh well you know she's really
a fan of waxes which is the rapper we
were there with she'll be back she'll go
I'll see her again and if you meant
really thought yeah yeah well I am can
because you're such a movie men like
that your whole life is a movie Wow cool
it so cute that's a movie right there
yeah the purple movie it's like girls
for me dream but she'll be back yeah I
mean you don't ever like see people in
ten knock you back a little bit maybe
have to say guys more than the girls I
don't know those guys are way more
visual I guess when it comes to finding
the partners again the honor I just kind
of knock him back into the below it was
my eyes your eyes your eyes but then
it's the way your eye is kind of you
know how many people smile it gets
smaller and so you have really big eyes
so I went to like regular size I guess
when you smile but then it was like the
full package of the smile with the eyes
I don't know another thing that please
man so that's what caught my eye that's
what really cemented like this
connection for me to you that's so cute
because yeah that night I didn't even
see you like I didn't know you were
there and I was a nervous we but I do
remember being at that show uh Network
but I remember first Anglin person was
at
the second whack show that you're
filming on the stage and then I remember
turning you around I was at Kiki's eat
and you turn around you're like hey and
I just immediately saw that jawline and
a good lip I was like but then I was
trying really hard to just be a good
girl cuz I'm still in a relationship by
that time hopefully no you can't let
your eyes wander but I I will admit that
I did you did catch in my eye with that
jawline like not mine I got a stay fit
thing is the person to go is the jawline
in to gain weight so I gotta you know I
like to turn to the side okay see this
little curve there's a little how it
kind of like slaps over there that and
then this it won me over I was like oh
man yeah yeah oh my gosh for the next
question
oh yeah question yeah
so for our last question from Yong Qi .
k Yong Chi Chi yeah uh what's an inside
joke between you guys guys you guys so
when we first met I had this really
thick cheek on my accent I never even
knew he like made me realize that I had
an accent and sometimes I could hear it
come out especially when I say like
three I'll be like three yeah so it was
it yeah was I know I know but usually
with three but anyway when was it that
you heard me say guy I don't know like
every time you mentioned the word guy it
was it wasn't guy it was God it was like
there's a whole bunch of like extra
vowel sounds coming like guy sounded
like it came from your cheek kinda
accent but it reminded me of how
Christopher Walken would say like this
guy you know know this guy I really mean
that
yes only on that words oh it was just
that words I know other words sound
electrical yeah so then from then on I
made it a point to just say guy like
normal I'm like guy oh yeah that guy
this guy but then like sometimes they'll
come out and he'll point it out and I
was like kind of our little inside joke
could be like thank an eye or sometimes
I'll even say it now purpose like what I
just did in the previous question really
got a guy yeah when you get all silly
and like fun that that the way you
pronounce the things that gets very
elongated like that yeah cousin of our
very first inflation it's not one of our
most recent inside jokes was you're
telling me something are now selling 11
oh we got to coach the girls even have
your bids going to do that because you
shoot two more or whatever whatever and
then you're like and you're like oh no
we have you know we have like five hours
here like two hours their mouth twenty
minutes to do that blanket time and all
there's like a like a 90 pound Ranger
like I was like Morphin times like funny
it's like serious they weren't cracking
up for like 30 minutes it was like the
funniest thing and it from then on were
just like oh we gotta hurry up and get
that thing plenty of time is that
there's only like a two minutes left on
the on the memory card plenty of time
[Laughter]
alright guys thanks for watching our
very first Q&A video we're gonna save a
lot of your questions that you guys
submitted that a lot there's like three
thousand question guys
ton so I'm not going to believe that
Instagram post so if you guys want to
keep adding questions to that and then
for future Q&A videos I'll just be
referring to that post one is on plenty
of time we got plenty of time for that
alright guys thanks for watching make
sure you give this video a big thumbs up
and see you next time hi hi
[Music]